today my quiet times are my solace my
respite and and I'm you know have an
amazing life today things weren't always
so amazing for Jodie Sweetin the actress
opened up about her past struggles with
addiction on this week's Dancing with
the Stars
drugs and alcohol just sort of numb and
everything I was doing cocaine and
ecstasy you know alcohol and all of that
the darkest moments for me weren't
necessarily like wine even a hospital or
anything that it was those quiet moments
alone when I just
hated the person that I'd become Jody
got emotional talking about how her drug
abuse affected her family I remember my
mom saying that when I was little I had
this light that shined really big and
that she'd watched my light become very
dark and I just remember my mom saying
to me like your light shines again today
Jody is five years sober her fuller
house co-stars Lori Loughlin and Bob
Saget praised her strength to see Jody
come out of the dark place and make it
to the other side
I think she's completely inspiring but
she's just incredibly real
and that's one of the things I love the
most about her it was really sweet to
see them come out and share so much love
you know and and be my family
Jodie's foxtrot earned her a score of 23
and plenty of compliments from the
judges and her family my family's
incredibly proud of me and you know
getting to share my story and dance
tonight like I did they my mom text me
immediately was like you were amazing
so it means the world to me